i definitely
when i was going through school i had no
joy
or delight in mathematics in fact i was
one of those kids who kind of just
i survived mathematics this is eddie wu
but i certainly didn't ever experience
it as a really positive like oh wow
this is a subject to be enjoyed and
appreciated um it was really far away
from my mind all the way through high
school
but eddie he actually ended up becoming
the one thing he
never thought he'd be a math teacher
it's really a testament to how my own
teachers
changed my own life i turned up at
university
with the full intent to become an
english and history teacher i went so
far as to have written that on my
enrolment form
but it was at university through some of
the educators whom i met there
that i discovered there's we don't have
enough mathematics
teachers and educators in our schools
really in any level
and when i heard about this suddenly all
these pieces kind of fell into place for
me because i realized
oh maybe this is not just about me and
my own experience of a subject
this is about something which is shaping
our society we've got
if we went out on the street today guy
and we asked 10 people
do you like mathematics i think nine of
them would tell us
no and that would probably be on a good
day i think you've got a bad day 10
would tell us no
we'd have to get further than that to
get to the first person who actually
likes it
and this is the effect that this
shortage of skilled and passionate and
engaged mathematics educators
that's the consequence of that shortage
in our culture and society i thought
i want to be an educator to make a
difference in people's lives if this is
where the need
is i'm going to go down the rabbit hole
you know there's a universal reality and
truth
to this subject that humanity has been
fascinated with for centuries for
millennia
and so i got to sort of stumble upon
that you know
really by accident and realize wow
there's a reason
why mathematicians describe mathematics
in these incredible terms
they describe it as elegant and it has
this austere
beauty it was as though guy you and i
we've kind of been born into this world
where no one
likes music they actually loathe it
because it's something they get forced
to do
when they're young everyone really hates
this particular style of music but you
have to go through learning how to write
the notes and how to
memorize the notes in sequence so you
can recite them in
a time pressure assessment task and then
thank goodness after 13 years of all
compulsory music we all just escape it
and we're very glad that we survived
having never actually listened to music
ourselves
that's a terrible way to describe a
world but that's the world we live in
because that's how people
think of mathematics
here's more from eddie wu on the ted
stage
i used to believe that maths was about
root learning inscrutable formulas
to solve abstract problems that didn't
mean anything to me
but at university i began to see that
mathematics is immensely
practical and even beautiful
but it's not just about finding answers
but also about learning to
ask the right questions it gradually
dawned on me
that mathematics is a sense
mathematics is a sense just like sight
and
touch it's a sense that allows us to
perceive realities which would be
otherwise
intangible to us now i want to show you
a mathematical reality
that i guarantee you've seen before but
perhaps never really
perceived it's been hidden in plain
sight
your entire life this
is a river delta it's a beautiful piece
of geometry
now when we hear the word geometry most
of us think of triangles and circles
but geometry is the mathematics of all
shapes
and this meeting of land and sea has
created shapes with an
undeniable pattern it has a
mathematically
recursive structure every part of the
river delta
with its twists and turns is a micro
version
of the greater whole so i want you to
see
the mathematics in this
but that's not all there's a
mathematical reality
woven into the fabric of the universe
that you share
with winding rivers towering trees and
raging storms
these shapes are examples of what we
call fractals as mathematicians
fractals get their name from the same
place as fractions
and fractures it's a reference to the
broken
and shattered shapes we find around us
in nature
now once you have a sense for fractals
you really do start to see them
everywhere ahead of broccoli
the leaves of a fern even clouds
in the sky like the other senses our
mathematical sense can be refined
with practice it's just like developing
perfect pitch
or a taste for wines you can learn to
perceive the mathematics around
you with time and the right guidance
[Music]
when people ask you a version of uh you
know
what am i going to do with this like
when am i ever going to use math
uh what do you say yeah it's
there's such a deep and profound
connection between all the mathematics
that i
learn and that i teach to my students
and literally their everyday lives
i think we need to understand that
mathematics is
so much more than numbers in fact you
know if we go back to the
because i'm such an english nerd i love
etymology and where words come from and
if
you dig into where the word mathematics
comes from literally
it just means understanding and that is
as
broad as the universe that we live in
the cosmos you know
biology is the study of living things
chemistry is the study of
substances and materials physics is the
study of
matter and movement but mathematics
is the study of patterns which are
literally
everywhere now what does this mean in
our everyday lives well
we are doing that yeah every hour of
every day
we are looking out at the world and we
are i'm just thinking about okay when i
get in my car
and i drive home you know i'm sitting in
this traffic and thinking about how to
get home i'm thinking about
all the paths that i can take which one
is going to be
the fastest the most efficient so i can
see my kids sooner um all of that
you're calculating you're thinking
logically in your mind
uh it goes to my perception of the world
when i look out
at a tree or at a rainbow i don't just
want to you know let this
these pieces of beauty pass me by what
it means to be human
is actually to marvel at this universe
around us
and to say wow there's a reason why
rainbows are round
why they're you know when you see a
rainbow after rain it looks like a
semicircle
you can see it you know hitting the
horizon but if you're lucky enough
and in the right place at the right time
if you're in the sky or on a mountain
you'll actually
see that rainbow's not a semicircle it's
a complete
full circle goes all the way around
that's not a coincidence
that's geometry that's beautiful what it
means to be human
is to appreciate that and say wow
there's something to wonder out here
and so for me you know when do i use
mathematics
when do i not use mathematics the real
question is do i know that i'm doing it
when i am
eddie i asked a version of this question
to dan finkel but
what's the danger of a society where
people don't engage with math or don't
have math competency or literacy
um i mean do you think there are
consequences
there are really severe consequences and
we've actually seen this
uh in our society today
in so many ways i could illustrate this
first can i play a
really really quick game with you guys
of course yeah i'd love to okay
we're going to go back and forth okay
and we're going to say numbers okay the
goal is either you or me
is going to say the number 23. okay and
whoever says the number 23 they're the
winner okay that's the goal
now guy i'll let you go first i want you
to choose a number between one and four
three three i'm gonna add a number to
that and it's always gonna be between
one and four
okay so i'm gonna say i'm gonna add one
to that so you said three
that means i say four it's your turn now
so
i'm gonna add uh a four uh i said four
so it's eight now yeah yep
i'm gonna say two so ten and i'm gonna
say four
fourteen okay no worries i'm gonna say
four now so
that means we're at 18. yep
what would you like to say now one
now i've i'm gonna make a bet you're
gonna bet you laughed
because you you realize it took you
about seven seconds
uh which is not bad guy um now i won't
give you the full explanation here but
how did i win that i knew something
about patterns underneath that game
which you didn't know
yeah and so i could take advantage of
that fact and
you know in this case what's the harm oh
i win no big deal right
but when you don't know what's going on
mathematically
underneath something and increasingly
today guy our world
is built on and is run by
algorithms that have been mathematically
designed by people
and are hidden from view you know when
you're scrolling through your social
media feed you're not thinking that
there's mathematics happening underneath
there
when you order something online and
there's recommended stuff
on the side for what people like you
guys have purchased these as well
you're not thinking about there's a
formula doing that but mathematics is
underneath
all of those things guiding all of those
people's decision making
and as i've just demonstrated if you're
not aware of that
someone can use that in a really
malicious way and people have used that
in really malicious ways and so you know
from a negative point of view what are
the consequences of us are having a
mathematically illiterate general
population
they're huge there's people who are
having the wool pulled over their eyes
and they don't
even know it but at the same time
i think we're missing a part of who we
are as human beings this is what i'm
sort of getting at
in the talk can you imagine if we walked
around
all day with our eyes closed can you
imagine if we went into the world
ignoring our senses we have our senses
because
they're a wonderful way to understand
and appreciate the world so not only are
there
really negative consequences but there
are really positive things
that we miss out and that i want people
to be able to feel and experience
and that for me is a really fundamental
reason i think mathematics
should be something everyone embraces
and learns
that's eddie wu he's a high school math
teacher in sydney australia
he also has his own channel on youtube
which of course is all about math
you can see eddie's full talk at ted.com
on the show today ideas about the beauty
of math
stay with us i'm guy roz and you're
listening to the ted radio hour
from npr